>>> THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS
MAKING PROGRESS IN INTERVIEWING
MEMBERS OF THERUMP CABINET.
ONE FOCUS OF THE QUESTIONING,
HOW SERIOUS WERE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT INVOKING THE TWENTY-FIFTH
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE TRUMP FROM
OFFICE AFTER THE CAPITOL RIOTS?
CNN HAS LEARNED THE FORMER
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY WAS
INTERVIEWED IN RECENT DAYS.
THE FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY,
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
ARE IN TALKS WITH THE COMMITTEE,
AS IS THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
SO FAR NINE FORMER TRUMP
OFFICIALS HAVE ENGAGED IN SOME
WAY, NINE, WITH THE COMMITTEE.
OUR REPORTERS ARE BACK NOW TO
DISCUSS, ONE OF THE TOPICS WE
KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED
IN IS HOW SERIOUS, WE KNOW THERE
WERE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SHOULD
WE INVOKE THE TWENTY-FIFTH
AMENDMENT AND SAY THE
PRESIDENT'S UNFIT, REMOVE HIM
FROM OFFICE?
BETSY DeVOS, HER SPOKESMAN SAYS
MAYBE SHE'S NOT NEGOTIATING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
>> I FELT THAT THERE WERE THINGS
THAT THE PRESIDENT COULD'VE DONE
TO STOP THE ACTIVITY TO TURN IT
BACK TO AVOID ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT ENSUED, AND IT WAS JUST A
BRIDGE TOO FAR.
I HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES, AND
THEN, IMPORTANTLY, I ALSO SPOKE
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT, AND HE
MADE CLEAR TO ME THAT THAT WAS
NOT A DIRECTION THAT HE WAS
GOING TO MOVE IN.
>> THERE IS A LOT THERE IN THE
SENSE THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
PRETTY RIGHT THERE CONFIRMATION
THAT THIS WAS A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION AMONG MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP CABINET AND THEN MIKE
PENCE WAS, LIKE, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
>> IT IS STRIKING THAT WE HAVE
NOW HAD A FORMER CABINET MEMBER
GO OUT THERE ON THE RECORD AND
CONFIRM THAT SHE WAS HAVING
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
TWENTY-FIFTH AMENDMENT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ELAINE CHAO
WAS HAVING DISCUSSIONS.
THEY FOUND OUT PRETTY QUICKLY
THAT THESE WERE UNLIKELY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN REMOVING HIM.
AND BOTH OF THOSE WOMEN TENDERED
THEIR RESIGNATIONS ON JANUARY
7th.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THE COMMITTEE
DOES WANT TO GET THE FULL
PICTURE OF JUST HOW DEEP-SEATED
THESE MISGIVINGS WERE IN THE DAY
BEFORE JANUARY 6th AND THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF JANUARY
6th, SO MUCH SO THAT PEOPLE WERE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING TRYING TO
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE.
>> THE COMMITTEE KNOWING THE
POLITICAL ATTACKS, BETSY DeVOS,
A MEMBER OF THE TRUMP CABINET.
ELAINE CHAO WAS A MEMBER OF THE
TRUMP CABINET.
THE COMMITTEE IS USING AS
WITNESSES AGAINST TRUMP.
>> I THINK IT SPEAKS TO THE
BROADER STRATEGY THE COMMITTEE
IS USING.
CLEARLY THEY'VE HAD TESTIMONY
NOW FROM ELAINE CHAO, FROM
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, WHO IS VERY
WELL INFORMED WHITE HOUSE AIDE.
I THINK IT SPEAKS TO THEIR
MESSAGE THAT THESE WERE PEOPLE
SURROUNDING THE PRESIDENT WHO
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT HIS FITNESS
FOR OFFICE.
AND I THINK BRINGING IN SOMEONE
LIKE ELAINE CHAO AND POTENTIALLY
BETSY DeVOS UNDERLINES THEIR
LINE OF INQUIRY INTO THE
TWENTY-FIFTH AMENDMENT INTO HOW
FIT THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
DURING THE AFTERMATH OF JANUARY
6th AND BEFORE THEN.
>> IT WILL BE STRIKING THEY'RE
SPENDING THE MONTH OF AUGUST
DOING THESE INTERVIEWS, AND THEN
WE EXPECT MORE PUBLIC HEARINGS
IN SEPTEMBER, SEPTEMBER BEING
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTION.
AGAIN, THE NORMAL MIDTERM ARC IS
IT'S ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND THE
PARTY THAT OWNS THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
HAS MADE SOME PRETTY DIARAMATIC
HEADLINES.
>> I THINK THEY'VE EXCEEDED
EXPECTATIONS IN WHO THEY'VE
GOTTEN TO TESTIFY PUBLICLY.
AND, TO YOUR POINT, A LOT OF THE
MIDTERMS IS GOING TO BE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IF HE DOES
DECIDE TO ANNOUNCE HIS RUN FOR
2024 BEFORE THE MIDTERMS, WHICH
THERE HAVE BEEN REPORTS HE MIGHT
DO.
HIS LEGAL PROBLEMS SEEM TO BE
GROWING.
AND IF THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO
TURN UP MORE INFORMATION THAT
THEY RELEASE CLOSER AND CLOSER
TO THE ELECTIONS, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS STILL TIED TO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IF YOU CAN PUT THE GRAPHIC UP
ON THE SCREEN, JUST LOOK AT THE
TREASURY SECRETARY, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, AMONG THESE CABINET
MEMBERS, THESE ARE TRUMP'S
PEOPLE.
>> ALSO EVEN THE FORMER LABOR
SECRETARY WHO I THINK WE WERE
SURPRISED, EVEN HE SAID HE
ENCOURAGED DONALD TRUMP TO
CONCEDE AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION.
SO I DO THINK THE COMMITTEE IS
GETTING A SENSE OF JUST HOW WIDE
THESE CONCERNS WERE.
>> FROM PEOPLE CLOSE, APPOINTED
BY THE PRESIDENT, LOYAL TO THE
PRESIDENT.